- [Announcer] Previously on Bro Dependent.
- Dude, this commercial
shoot is like, legit as fuck.
(grunts)
It's another photo of a dong,
what the fuck is wrong with her phone?
- She's fucking other guys.
- Wow, fuck this, I'm out.
- What?
- That's our thing, don't do that.
- Do you think I could buy some?
- Just sort of keep this on the down-low
but also like, tell all
your friends, all right?
- Yeah.
(dance music)
(hammer smashes)
- Fuck.
Fuck you.
Hey.
Oh.
For you.
Fuck.
Oh, sick.
(grunts)
Take that, Zack.
- Hi, Andy, it's good to see
you, you're getting so big.
- Oh, thanks Dr. Murphy, you too.
Hey, are you just like,
throwing out these cool knives?
- Oh, oh no, put it back.
- Oh.
- Put it back.
- Okay, okay I'm sorry.
- Okay, so what are you here for?
Are the bumps back?
- No, I'm working on this like,
really exciting energy drink project.
- Oh, good for you.
- Oh, thanks Dr. Murphy,
but oxycottton is like, super
expensive on the black market
so can you get me some, like for cheap?
Like, I need like, 20
big bottles, you know,
with no child-proof tops, write that down.
- Andy, that's a very
addictive controlled substance.
Are you taking that?
- Only a little.
I'm mostly selling it.
Wait, Dr. Murphy, are you
playing hardball with me?
I'm gonna give you a
cut, you little bitch.
- Stop it.
- Ow.
- I want you to go, just go.
- Okay, stop talking
to me like I'm a puppy.
I'll do it the legit way.
Oh, and the bumps are back
so good job with that.
In conclusion, who drinks energy drinks?
Tired people.
Who gets tired?
Everybody.
Quatro Cotton, business opportunity.
It's fucking foolproof as fuck.
I need 10K today or my business
dies, what do you say, mom?
- So you're dealing drugs now?
- No, no, I'm like,
dealing an energy drink
with a drug in it, it's very different.
- Oh my god, it's a great idea.
- I can tell that you don't
think it's a great idea.
- [Caroline] Well I do.
- Fuck you, Caroline.
- Fuck you.
- Like, why don't you go to your room
and go fuck yourself.
- No, I'm doing something.
No, I don't wanna fuck--
- stop it.
- Mom, she's like, fucking my best friend
and it's like, torn us apart.
- Oh my god, you are not.
- What?
- Oh, you go, girl.
- Thanks, mom.
- That's pretty amazeballs.
- Stop, oh god, sluts stop,
you're derailing my moment.
Mom, please like, look,
I tried to like, source the
oxycotton from Dr. Murphy
but you know how like, old women are,
they're just like "no, it's illegal".
- Anderson, I am not
investing in your drug drink.
- Please, I made you a fucking poster.
- No.
(all argue)
- Oh my god, Zack, thank
god, something good today,
I forgive you, okay.
- Dude, I'm not here to talk to you.
- What?
- My love.
I suck at this but I wanna be the fly
that gets caught in your vagina web.
Will you marry me?
- Oh my god, no.
- What?
- Zack, I haven't seen you in like, a week
and I text you pictures
of other dudes' dicks.
We're broken up.
- Wait, what?
- Honey, remind me, is this
tattoo penis or long balls?
- No, this is the one
that cries when he cums.
- Right.
(retches)
- Oh, ew, ew, ew.
- Oh my god, it's happening.
Zack, Zack, dude, it's okay, Zack.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, why, why the
fuck did you do this?
Oh god, it's okay, it's okay.
Stop staring at us!
(both groaning)
There's nothing left,
get back, give him space,
give him some space.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
- You are such a little bitch.
- Are you fucking happy?
Are you fucking happy?
- [Caroline] Yeah.
(Zack sobbing)
- Hey, thanks for watching Bro Dependent.
Don't forget to subscribe
and check out more at comedycentral.com
and fuck, something else.
What...
Uhh...
(retches)
Oh.
Oh, comment, you can leave
comments in the comment section.
Thanks.